[Music]
my husband works on the road how long's
he been doing that 15 years now he's
been doing that woo do you have kids uh
we do but they are growing so 25 and 22
so they're out of the home now okay okay
oh so You' you've been a single parent
for 15 years I have
[Music]
yeah yo yo yo what's up this is John
with the Dr John delone show the
greatest mental health and marriage and
emotional health and parenting schools
podcast
ever so glad that you joined us I think
I just went through puberty just then my
voice cracked hey I'm so glad you're
with us on this show we take real calls
from real people going through
challenges um at home going through
challenges at work going through
challenges in their marriages and
relationships with their with their
providers everybody's struggling right
now and here's my promise on this show
I'll sit with you and we will figure out
what happens next if you want to be on
the show give me a buzz at 1844 693 3291
it's 1844 693 3291 or go to johal.com
askk and while you're at john.com pick
up questions for humans save your
holidays save your holidays I got you
and pick up building a non-anxious life
number one bestseller um just continues
to fly out the door and um I want
everybody to have nothing says I love
you for the
holidays Merry Christmas family youall
all need this book that's fantastic all
right let's go out to California a and
talk to the extraordinary Emily what's
up Emily hey how's it going partying
what are you up to good I'm hiding in my
car
so just loud and proud it loud and proud
roll down the windows and let them know
what's up all right so I'll just start
with my question and then yeah if you
have questions you can interrupt me but
um so my question is am I wrong in not
showing my emotions to others and then
just to explain that a little bit I
wrote um I'm pretty I'm a pretty
even-tempered person I don't have like
big vary in my emotions like either
happy or sad I'm just pretty even keeled
and more specifically when I do have
emotions I don't really show them to
others I'm more private with them um and
I just feel like this seems to be
abnormal for like girls in general um
but I've been this way since I can
remember like since I was a teenager but
recently me and my husband we sat down
with someone and we talked for with him
for about an hour and at the end of the
hour he made some comment and he said
that he pegs me for someone that doesn't
show much emotion and for some reason
having a stranger tell me that and Peg
me so easily bothered me so I would like
to get your Insight on that well I don't
know that it was like
I don't think he was like you know uh
like working at hogart I if he talked to
you for an hour and you talking about
some heavy things and you didn't show
emotion he was just commenting on uh you
don't show emotion maybe that's true so
it's not like he was like you know what
I mean like uh so let me ask you this
where did you learn to be even
Keel I don't I don't know I knew you was
going to ask that and so I was I was
actually talking to my sister about it I
don't know that I can say I do remember
like when I was young my parents never
like like got me in trouble for showing
emotion or anything but I do remember
like my mom would go visit her parents a
lot and they lived out of state so we
didn't get to see them very much and
they would all be very sad when when we
would leave and I just remember thinking
like I'm going to be the one that
doesn't cry but I don't know why I don't
know why I thought that that was just
kind of in my head gotcha you showed
them huh I guess I I think I see it as a
sign of strength but I don't look at
people that show emotion as being weak
at least
not I don't know maybe deep down I
do so
I here's kind of my my
thinking emotions are shared in or
they're expressed in a variety of ways
and I've seen people who have really
awful things right like gnarliest of
gnarly friends loved ones whatever um
and they don't cry or they are go into
kind of a dark hole for four or five
days and then they're kind of back out
back at it and I've had I've sat with
people and they're like dude everyone's
telling me like I'm gonna feel like this
or this is gonna happen or and it just
doesn't I just am kind of on to the next
and so I think that that is equally a
valid expression of your what your body
is working through as any other you know
I need to be out for 5 months um David
Kessler says grief is like a fingerprint
it's Unique to everybody right and so
once like your body's AO of expression
it's it's Unique to you what I would ask
is is this a way that you
either exert power in a
situation and I would ch you on like oh
watch this I'm not going to cry I'm
going to stuff it so far down into my
soul just watch or you actually didn't
feel it like I'm I mean I'm sad but I
don't feel like like my body doesn't
feel like it it's going to cry um or
that's a superpower that you put out
into the world to protect yourself now
right so it's either a way to get power
or it's a way to defend
yourself and if it's not then great I
would tell you you have to have somebody
that you tell the hard stuff to that
doesn't mean you have to cry and kick
and
scream do you have that person those
people that's not your
spouse
yes are you honest with them kind of
kind
of I don't know that I share easily
that's okay I think we have a culture of
oversharing so I don't have problem with
that at
all yeah I do I do I have a group of
friends that have walked through life
with so give me an example of a time you
shared what you were
feeling well okay to them so we me and
my husband went through a really rough
patch two years ago like not between us
but just in life I had some significant
health problems and stuff so I would say
like during that time
I would share like what was going on and
stuff with them would you share
clinically like I've got this ailment
and this I'm taking this medication or
would you
say I'm scared our sex life is never
going to get back the way it was I'm
scared my husband's going to leave
me um probably in between that
okay yeah I would say in between that
okay sometimes people say I'm not very
emotional I don't like to share my
emotions
and that's them giving themsel a pass on
keeping secrets and those are two
different
things
okay I'm super okay if you don't wail
and kick and scream I'm a wailer and
kicker and screamer Kelly is not she's
not and in fact Kelly um and Kelly you
can pop in here I don't want to tell
your story for you
but we talked about how when she was
diagnosed with with breast cancer
several years ago that she spent most of
her energy making sure everybody in
around her was was fine that would beat
me right
exactly
but that doesn't mean you get a pass on
sitting down with somebody and saying
hey I'm actually scared to death yes it
does it that was Kelly it doesn't
because um Secrets have a biological
toll they take on your
body so do you get the difference
between emotions and secrets as I'm
describing them I may not be doing a
good job no no yeah no I think I do okay
so yeah dude I I here here's what I
would do I would spend 30 days having a
conversation with yourself in a
notebook do you do
that no because whenever you say that
I'm like how do people find time to do
that oh
sweetheart I have four little kids so my
time is about 30 minutes in the evening
before I go to bed to do all the things
I disagree with you that's the time you
allow
yourself okay
here I don't want to speak something
into the universe that's not true okay
because I don't want to send somebody on
a spelunking Expedition down into the
caverns of their soul for no reason but
it is not uncommon that somebody looks
at the world as it is laid in front of
them and as my friend Ian said simkin
says if busyness is your drug rest will
feel like
stress I don't have time I have this job
to do and this list to do and I will get
through the list and everyone has to eat
everyone has to poop and everyone has to
wipe and all the dishes have to be done
and all of this has to be done and what
all of those tasks which do have to get
done they become a way to not
feel and they become an
addiction because they allow me to be
busy instead of to experience
what I'm actually feeling about all this
stuff because when you feel it and
experience it that's when you have a
hard conversation with your husband and
say hey I need some help around here or
I really wanted to be a mom and have
four kids and I'm burning out too and so
can we hire a house cleaner once a month
or can we can I work half a day once a
week so I can talk to adults about
things other than poo and
pee but if you don't ever give yourself
a space
which by the way give yourself another
30 minutes for God's sake
right if you don't give yourself that
space your body is keeping the score the
whole time as Vander CK
says yeah that's probably true and then
one day you'll explode have you had a
good one a good just Rip Roar that
that's the thing is I hold it in and
then I will I will show my emotion in
probably anger or
frustration gosh you you know what you
could do for a living is be a producer
of pretty good podcast because you're
exactly like my friend Kelly
exactly
um here's what I I always I tell my
husband it's dangerous when I have time
to think because then like yeah like you
said you go down that Rabbit Trail it's
dangerous when you have time to think
it's deadly when you
don't that's a good
point
H so here's your challenge find two or
three things that you can ask him to
help around the house with and that
doesn't mean he's not working his butt
off at his job and that doesn't mean
he's not tired
either that means there's only so much
of you to go
around and give yourself 30 days to
write down in a journal in a
notebook and it could be as simple as
here's five things I'm grateful for
here's five things that I'm not grateful
for just be honest and it might take two
or three weeks of doing this to slowly
peel back some of those layers my guess
is it was not
cool for you to cause a scene when you
were a
kid yeah I don't know I just didn't I
don't know if it was cool not I think
they would my parents would have been
fine with it but yeah no there was a
sense of like we act this way in the
culture we grew up in yeah
so I get yeah that's probably partly
true and that's not necessarily a bad
thing right
but I don't want your kids feeling that
energy that nuclear reactor inside your
chest that's always kind of
buzzing that you don't deal with except
when it just overflows and becomes a
volcano in your living room I don't want
them Fe I I'm people worry about that
explosion it's not great right when
yelling and screaming and slamming
cabinets or whatever it is you do
but that's not what I'm more mostly
worried about I'm more worried about the
dayto day the perace the pervasive
burn it's always there that those four
little kids are wondering 247 what am I
doing I love her she's so great she
never blows up at us she doesn't scream
or hit us but she doesn't feel
safe that's what I'm that's what I'm
hoping for
and that doesn't mean you have to scream
and cry and have big swings and all that
everybody's different when it comes to
that and it's okay if you don't want to
overshare you want to keep some things
private just to have a couple of people
that you're fully open with great that's
totally
awesome but there's a difference between
feeling there's a difference between
emotion and then and keeping
secrets my guess is if you make it a
regular practice to not keep secrets
from your husband to not keep secrets
from two or three close close friends
over time your body will feel permission
to
feel and to let some stuff go and to
drop your shoulders and to finally say
some things out loud like things that
you need and things that you're
frustrated by and things that you
love I'll leave you with this if you're
constantly stomping on the stuff you
don't have time to deal with I got time
for
that then over time you're going to also
con unconsciously be stomping out
joy
laughter tons of
fun Reckless romance with your husband
those things get squashed
too and I want you to have it
all have it all thank you so much for
the call Emily you're awesome we'll be
right
back hey delone here good folks our
society has devalued sleep we're told to
keep working and grind through the
fatigue and pretend that we don't need
sleep then this crazy culture tries to
shame us when we do hit the sack at a
normal time I'm here to tell you 7 to9
hours of refreshing sleep is essential
for all aspects of your physical and
mental health and to help with that I
recommend investing in an amazing
mattress getting great sleep is
priceless but a premium mattress can
cost a lot and that's a big reason why I
love dreamcloud dreamcloud mattresses
are made with premium materials for half
the cost of other premium mattresses
they use Advanced Technologies to keep
you comfortable all night for a great
price and the exclusive deal they're
offering my listeners can help even more
right now dreamcloud is offering my
listeners 40% off all mattresses plus an
additional $50 discount go to dreamcloud
sleep.com and enter code John deloney
today that's dreamcloud sleep.com with
code John deloney
all right we are back and let's take a
call that's not so close to home like
right in the booth yeah that'd be great
it was a little uh little too close for
me go with the ychy on that one let's go
out to Omaha and talk to Jeff hey Jeff
what's up man hey not much just uh well
took your anxiety test and well I'm a
little worried because I scored red in
every category that there was rro all
right so want me through it
man well I I don't even know where to
start because yeah I think I scored a
yellow in belief but that's like I think
that's more Church related or religious
or I read it said worshiping stuff and I
don't think I really worship anything
you know okay well I guess besides God
but yeah okay so backing out you have a
lot of red and a yellow did that ring
true to you or did you think well maybe
the quiz is broken well I'm thinking
maybe I just think it's my normal where
other people would see it would be a
red you don't get an exemption on
Humanity yeah that's why I'm calling you
um what's going what's going on in your
life oh I could probably tell you 20
different things tell all 20 of them rip
them off let's go well I was a little
over EXA but I got uh well we got four
kids one's four or no one yeah one's
four one's two one is one and we got one
in the oven yet at 22 or 23 weeks
and then my wife moved her friend in
with us and we just have this little
modular 800 foot home to help with
bills and I started a new job path of
owning my own Auto Repair business that
just kicked off last week so a little
bit of everything I
guess so I don't know how to say this
nicely your body is sounds like it is
working about perfectly
yeah well it's been this way before all
because all this new stuff just happened
the past couple weeks but yeah it I
probably would have scored the same
before that and it would have been a
different version of the same chaos
Fair
yeah where did you learn to live in
chaos man this is an acquired
taste well oh I guess my family grew up
a little bit different than my wife's
where her family's all kind of touch
feely and talk everything and my
family's kind of like keep to yourself
and I don't think I've ever hugged my
dad before Oh man but it's like it's a
normal thing like I don't feel bad about
it or anything I know dude but the the
title of Bessel cul's book Vander clk's
book is the body keeps the score whether
you want to keep it or not yeah right
and that's why I'm always like with my
kids um we have the three girls that are
the oldest which that's probably a a
whole headache there but I'm always like
I give them hugs and everything they
need so I know cuz when you have parents
like that you know you don't that's not
the way you want to raise them who's
giving Jeff what Jeff
needs um I I'm just trying to take care
of everyone I kind of like to put myself
last I know and your body is telling you
that it's about to
quit it's about to quit
yeah why with three teeny tiny ones and
then a fourth on the way did you decide
to open up your own mechanic
shop
well I'm really not sure it's my
understanding is mechanic shops take
several years to become profitable right
um not so much because I started out on
the farm we own so we're not making
payments and uh I'm mobile so like I
don't really have a lot of overhead okay
I have a I have a buddy that runs a sixf
figure Mobile Oil Change business so I
I've seen that done up close and it's
pretty amazing so cool but you still
have to build a book of
business yeah which that's why we moved
back to my uh Hometown where I grew up
on the farm where I I'm local I know
people in the area and I've already had
quite a bit of business but also your
body may have put some GPS pins in and
living local and living back on the farm
it remembers life wasn't so great
sometimes
Fair yeah but we lived in uh in Omaha
inside the ca limits and it that
stresses me out like crazy just being
packed full with everyone and I like out
in the open okay wh why in the world is
this a good time for a
roommate uh well it's it was hard it was
a hard decision because it's my wife's
best friend she's a single mom and she's
like she's really struggling and I think
she sees it as like her own like it's
her way I don't know like some with she
said she prayed on it and she said that
she needs to be there for her and help
her
and I'm not really I like her decide on
it mostly because you know she's the one
in the house you
know prob sounds B but she's like the
one that has to deal with it I guess
more where I'm you know I'm out working
more yeah that's a that's a cursory
glance at it you're right but you're the
one that has to come
home to a devastated and exhausting
pregnant
wife and a four yearold and a
two-year-old and a
one-year-old and somebody else's kid how
many kids does she have the roommate
well she's got she's got two but they're
uh one you know they're kind of they go
to their dads and stuff so kind of off
and
on in an 800 squ foot house yeah uh cuz
we moved it here and hopes that we were
going to start building our house here
in a in a year or two there's no chance
you can do that yeah it's starting to
seem more like that
yeah so
here's here's where I think you should
start
okay that wheel that six daily choices
wheel is supposed to be a road map and
when all seven are
red I want you to look and say okay
what's the easiest entry point for me
here and I know you have a lot of
obligations but what you're telling me
is to use a farm analogy I have a ton of
hey that's got to get bailed out
there and your dad is telling you I know
but you got to change the oil and put
gas in the tractor and you're saying I
don't have time for that I got to bail
the
hay and you know as well as I do that
six stripes in the field that tractor is
going to park itself and it's going to
Brick itself right yeah so the best
thing to do to get all that hay bailed
is to stop and take care of that
tractor and continue to take care of
that tractor while you're bailing the
hay
fair fair okay you're no better than a
tractor right now actually are way
better than a tractor but the analogy
works
so I want you just to look at that thing
and
pick all you don't get a pass on all six
of them dude I went down the nerd
research with the scientist I went back
to old religious Traditions not just
Christian but all I mean dude you don't
get a pass on it so if you don't have
one or two men in your life that you go
regularly hang out
with you're body knows oh all of this is
on you all of it if your business fails
if um your wife and your four kids plus
the single mom and her two kids if one
thing goes sideways everybody's
out your body knows that and it would be
failing you with that kind of stress to
let you sleep all
night it would be failing you if the
moment you open your eyes it didn't just
flood the system with cortisol because
it is at
War and so you have to do the hard work
you move back to your hometown you got
to find one or two men that you go out
once a week and just go hang out with
and you're going to think I don't have
time for that and I'm telling you that
your body doesn't have time for you not
to and then we're just going to go
around the go around when's the last
time you went to a doctor and got a
checkup um probably a few years yeah
it's time go get some blood work
done go have your doctor check your um
uh blood pressure and your give you a
blood
test well blood pressure I have the oh
the hospital reaction where my blood
pressure is fine at home then if I'm in
a doctor that stresses me out so it goes
High okay don't solve that at home
inside of your 800 foot trailer tell
your doctor that they're not dumb
despite what some people on YouTube
think okay and then we're just going to
go around the go around the
list but I want you to decide what about
choosing Freedom how much money do y'all
owe you have any debt yeah we got yeah
we got debt that's that's another reason
why I wanted to start this new career
because more uh better money coming in
is that actual better better money is it
real yeah okay yeah actually the few
weeks I've been going it's been yeah a
lot better okay are you is that include
putting 25% aside or 30% aside because
you're going have to pay small business
tax um yeah that's still putting yeah
after all of our taxes and deductions
and everything that's still coming out
ahead okay um it might be for a season
you got to do that and then the evenings
you got to drive Uber deliver pizzas I
don't know what you can do out in the
country out there but you might have to
work for a season extra hard yeah well
and I've been doing a side gig also
besides Auto Repair great but I want you
and your wife to do that with a plan
after this call is over I'm going to
send you two copies of the book and I'm
going to S send you financial piece
university and I'm going to send you
every dollar app for a year okay okay
that's going to be a road map across a
bunch of different fronts but listen if
you owe somebody money if your
Calendar's bananas if your house is so
chaotic with six kids under the age of
four plus two moms trying to figure out
what dude of course of course your body
is s singing the alarms off the wall
just banging banging banging banging the
alarms of course if you call and like no
dude everything's great I'm sleeping
like a baby I would tell you go to the
doctor now something's not right right
that is the one thing I do get is eight
hours of sleep at night I will say
that I would I I would love for you to
track that
sleep I bet it is very thin either that
or your body has figured out the magic
way to just go into a black hole as
self-preservation
all that to say is
this find one Avenue and go down that
rabbit hole and I want you and your wife
to sit down and be honest with the first
step choosing
reality yes that single mom friend of
hers needs help and support and
love but three little ones plus a brand
new business plus a fourth baby on the
way may may have may not be the moment
for youall I don't know how youall have
enough space in this little place like
just literal physical
space and so I want you to choose
reality and to begin to go down and say
okay where can we choose peace over
chaos
exercise health and healing
relationships y'all can't have anybody
over you got too much chaos
right yeah
yeah and you're going to have to decide
to choose peace in this season if you
don't then I mean it's a choice you're
making but don't blame the anxiety don't
blame the anxiety
test blame the world you and your wife
have
created and I say blame the world like
it's not a bad thing it's just a very
very very chaotic
life you're asking your body to do
something it wasn't designed to do which
is everything all at once all at the
same time while being indebted while
having no exit strategy while having we
hope to build in two years you don't
have a road map you don't even have a
financial map to get there or a business
plan or I need to be making this much
money by this date and I'm going to
check in with these two guys once a week
just to make sure I'm on track you don't
have any of that stuff your body is
screaming at you so hang on the line I'm
going send you two copies of building a
non-anxious life I'm going to give you
the road map
for the finances allow you and your wife
to get connected you'reall going to have
to decide hey if we're going to do all
this stuff we have to choose peace over
chaos wherever we
can it's going to be chaotic with four
little ones it's going to be chaotic
starting a new job in a new town in a
new business in an 800t
trailer what chaotic moments outside of
those two things can we begin to shed so
that we don't all implode cuz as I said
at the beginning of this call that
tractor is about to stop in the middle
of the field and then everybody's
done you are worth being well we'll be
right
back this episode is sponsored by better
help hey what up what up it's delone
this time of year can be so hard and
Seasonal effective disorder is real when
I moved here the time change caught me
off guard it was dark at 4:30 and I was
ready for bed at like 6:45 at night
things weren't as fun even food tasted
different and now I know how to prepare
my body I go outside and enjoy nature I
stick to an exercise routine I got a
light box and I intentionally connect
with people another thing that has
helped me therapy therapy can be a
bright spot even when the Sun goes down
too soon something positive to help you
feel grounded and give you the tools to
manage the way your body is changing
during the seasons if you're thinking of
starting therapy give better help a try
better help is flexible because it's
totally online so it can fit into your
schedule just fill out a short
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and you can switch
therapist anytime for No Charge find
your bright spot this SE season with
betterhelp visit betterhelp.com delone
today to get 10% off your first month
that's betterhelp
hp.com
dealone all right let's go out to8 mile
at Detroit Rock City and talk to an
what's up
Ann oh not much thanks for taking my
call Dr John of course what's up um well
I have a h some dilemmas or problems um
I've been married for 25 years and um my
husband works on the road so he is out
of the home Monday through um Friday
returns Friday evening um oh dang and so
how long's you been doing that um since
let's see it's about 15 years now he's
been doing
that yes do you have kids so uh we do
but they are growing so this is where
the problem really lies now they're
growing or they're grown they're growing
so 25 and 22 so of the home now okay
okay oh so You' you've been a single
parent for 15 years I have yeah what is
your H very active one at that so they
kept me very busy and um so it wasn't as
difficult as it is now for me um with
him on the road all the time what's he
do he is he a driver no he works on the
high electrical lines power
lines so he's like an actual actual
stud yeah yeah gosh
dude okay so he's gone and so now that
the kids are gone I'm spending a lot
obviously time at home by myself and and
feeling very lonely and um it's it's
just very difficult um to throw a little
Notch into everything um he uh we live
on the Family Farm And so he has this
desire to continue the tradition of
farming with his you know that's been in
the farm for generations and generations
and so his weekends are pretty much
occupied with farming also yeah
so here's what I would recommend youall
do if you haven't already I would
recommend that you call some
sort
of romantic getaway
weekend would he do
that at certain times of the year you
know obviously right now it's hard
because it's harvest time so it's even
more amped up than normal when does
Harvest Time roll
out um it usually starts anywhere from
September and goes through depending on
the weather um through
November okay I want you to put November
15th on the
calendar November 21st on the calendar
and that's going to go right into Deer
Hunt season I get it
but here's what has to happen you all
have to get together and
say we've been married for a quarter
Century 15 years ago you went to do this
work and I raised these kids essentially
on my
own I want us to make a
plan for the back half of our Lives how
old are you right
now I'm 44 okay you got about halfway
done at some point you have to have the
courage to say
I don't want to continue doing this in
two more years or five more
years I want to paint a new picture of
what the back half of our life is going
to look like and I have expressed that a
little bit um and and even come up with
some ideas of strategies of things that
we could possibly do um to help some of
this
situation one you know obviously he
can't walk away from all these years
that he's put into this company either
he absolutely 100% could the
retirement could care
less he's not going to lose all the
retirement is
he part of it he would yes
okay what's what's what's the number
what's the number for his
wife while I'm willing up to give up my
job and relocate where he does most of
the the work to make this work okay so
to me that's a lot because I also have
established you know relationships and
things at my work but I can do my work
other places um the need that that the
line of work I'm in there's a need
everywhere so I can find a job
easily I don't know what the when that
was brought up it was like well then we
have to purchase another house and are
we going to be able to afford it and I
do all the finances y'all are going
about this all
backwards y'all are going through you
are saying you know I'm kind of what if
we thought about and like this
is and immediately he'll kick into
problem solving mode as most men do and
he'll come up with a reason or two or
three why this won't
work and then you cash
out mhm so my question to you is how
much longer under the current
Arrangement are you in
for not much that's
right my guess is you are way closer to
the end than you are letting on or that
your friends probably even know
absolutely
and my gut tells me he has a second life
somewhere not with a family or anything
like I'm saying he's running around has
seven kids somewhere else but he has a
whole other life that you're not a part
of is that
fair and part of you is really pissed
off that he missed your kid's
life resentment yep Y at the same time
you're really grateful that he's
provided a good living for everybody
Fair correct y both and
and I believe with all my guts that
there is a season when a and I'm going
to over genderize this so everybody hold
your breath
when men go to work and do things they
hate away from people they love because
they have to get something done I
believe that I can imagine in 2008 in
Detroit saying I'm going to go find
something to do because the world was
imploding around everybody I get that
2009 about right yeah I get that
and I think you can cheat on your wife
with your job
I think you can cheat on your wife with
a golf
course I think you can cheat on your
wife with any number of
things the challenge here is you can't
control any of that what you can control
is how clear you're being and I don't
want you for the sake of not rocking the
boat or the sake of not causing you know
this or
that I think it's time to be very very
clear and it will probably be like a ton
of bricks out of left field for him you
think or no yes absolutely okay I think
you have to own that because you
probably should have had this
conversation seven years ago Fair yeah
yeah why didn't
you you're not supposed to ask why
questions but I'm just
curious just because I was so active
with my own career at the time and very
busy and then like like I said the kids
were in and out for a while and then
they're finally like establish their own
lives and then I just felt like I was
left in the
dust did you also leave him in the
dust um no but I don't schedule my life
around him anymore because he doesn't do
the same for
me so let me ask you a hard question are
you
done
no convince me or
not when we're together I love the time
that we have well of course I mean it
has no strings to it you can have a
weekend rendevu and fall under whatever
religious Dominion that you've ascribed
to and then you can go about having
whatever job and day and life and
friends you
want just because you have fun on a
weekend with somebody doesn't mean your
marriage is
solid I definitely know it lacks some
communication otherwise I would have
that was awesome I mean it's kind of
lacking a little you know yes you've
been keeping this secret for 10 years
now what what keeps you from quitting
your job and showing up on the doorstep
of the apartment he lives in or the
hotel he lives been living out of for 15
years and say I miss you so much I can't
breathe
probably I to be honest
what I've created for
myself MH just the stability of being
able to you know I'm independent like I
can support myself I know but to what
end you're flexing for yourself right
into the end of your
marriage
yep like your words are saying no I want
to fix this I want to solve this but
every action I see from both of you he
was like no no this thing is just like a
cool weekend
arrangement I think in the back of our
heads both of us are just like when we
can retire which is in still seven years
this will be
different what's gonna be
different just that we'll be together I
guess I don't know because the
communication isn't going to get better
on its own
no and you're going to wake up up and
realized you waited your whole life to
live and you'll be 53 years
old
yeah and then what suddenly he's going
to be like all right let's play checkers
every evening
together
right and vice versa you're just going
to want like all right now we can have
sex all the time really like that's just
not just gonna
happen right
I I
I I mean yeah how can I help I I I is it
too late for counseling should we do
counseling like you haven't even had the
conversation
yet that's I'm trying that's that's what
I'm just kind of stuck I don't know
what's so hard about the
conversation that you sit down and you
tell them hey for 15 years you've done
what you want to do I've built an
amazing career and amazing life here I
want you home you got 6 months to wrap
it up I don't care how much money we
lose I want you
or honey you've worked your butt off 15
years hanging from high wires doing
whatever it is you do I'm quitting all
this stuff I'm
out yeah or the third option is hey I've
been a single mom for 15 years you've
been a rough neck for 15 years all by
yourself and we get together
for we hook up a couple of times a month
and we sit by each other at graduation I
love you always will but this marriage
is over let's just be grown-ups about it
because I love my career too much you
love your career too much and this farm
and I've got half of my life left to
live and I don't want to be third place
behind this fantasy you have about being
a farmer and you're out of Town
job and you don't want to be second
place to or third place to my role as
mom and dad that I created and my job as
a
whatever right that's the third
option but I don't think it's time for
counseling yet because y'all haven't
even told each other the
truth and again the conversation needs
to be have for sure
are you g to do it because I'm sure he's
got his stuff to say too doesn't he oh
I'm sure yeah it needs to happen it
definitely needs to happen I don't see
it's either that or walk away I mean
those are really in my eyes the only two
options I know but I don't think he
realizes how close you are at option
b do you already have
somebody nope not even a little bit nope
what about over 15 years
never what about
him
same are you positive I'm positive what
are you scared of
then this usually happens somebody's
this scared to have this conversation
for this long is they're scared of an
abusive response or they're scared of
something they're going to find and
they'd rather I'm I'm scared of probably
a
failing
at my
marriage I have come from a background
of a very strong
marriage parents have been married over
you know well over 50 years I know but
you're not living their
life and this is like a conversation
with my son when I'm looking at like a
worksheet with a zero on it and I'm
looking at two missing assignments and
another worksheet with a 50 on it and he
says I'm so scared of failing and I look
at him and say you are
because the marriage isn't this thing
that's way over there the marriage is
the telling the truth the marriage is
the phone calls the marriage is
sacrifice the marriage is I don't care
what job I have nothing's worth
you and that's both of
you so like marriage isn't this thing
over here it's a thousand different
decisions yall make along the
way and it's a choice to always be in
service to and him always be in service
service to somewhere along the way y'all
started being service to yourselves and
here we
are I would be less worried about you
failing in being scared of failing in
marriage and more scared of you waking
up being 45 years old on an island which
is what I think you've done
right and your kids acted as a Xanax for
15 years of loneliness and isolation and
being by yourself
Fair
yes I think it's time to set up the
conversation and I would recommend it I
mean after this long I'd recommend
writing it down you might take two or
three drafts of this but I would write
it
down and I would give him a heads up and
say hey we need to have a conversation
about the state of our marriage and the
state of us staying together what what
what yeah we need to have a conversation
about the state of our marriage I
haven't told you everything over the
last 15 years and I got to put
everything out on the table and I hope
you'll honor me and do the same
thing but something's got to give
because the whole thing's about to fall
over and I don't know another way to do
that I
don't but a fear of
failure every day every week every month
is actually creating the future you're
terrified of having
have the hard conversation and if it
reveals a marriage that's an ash y'all
can decide to build something new and
it's going to be real hard but it can
absolutely be done or if you reveal a
marriage Hanging On by a thread and both
of you are all in and he's like oh my
gosh I'll quit today cool or you say I'm
out cool or both of you say I love my
job I love my job I love our we love our
jobs more than we love this thing that
we've created you need to be honest and
have that conversation
too I think the time for avoidance is
over we have to head directly into this
hard conflict and come up with some
solutions by the way an you're not the
only one most people on the planet need
to do that right now head towards the
storm thanks for the call we'll be right
[Music]
back hey what's up delone here listen
you and me and everybody else on the
planet has has felt anxious or burned
out or chronically stressed at some
point in my new book building a
non-anxious life you'll learn the six
daily choices that you can make to get
rid of your anxious feelings and be able
to better respond to whatever life
throws at you so you can build a more
peaceful nonanxious life get your copy
today at johal.com
all right we're back hey as we wrap up
today's
show finally one of my my favorite
singers of all time ever The Great and
Wonderful Nina Simone the song is called
feeling
good birds flying high you know how I
feel sun in the sky you know how I feel
Breeze Drifting On by you know how I
feel it's a new dawn it's a new day it's
a new life for me and I'm feeling good
fishing the sea River Running Free
Blossom on a tree it's a new dawn it's a
new day it's a new life for me and I'm
feeling good and I hope you're feeling
good too love you guys stay in school
don't do drugs
[Music]
bye